all right let's close out with a great
story from the world of social media
this is what I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
liking so it's dry January the time
after the holidays when people try to
cut back on alcohol good luck Shelton uh
but cutting back doesn't mean you can't
enjoy a night out here in Manhattan
there's a bar dedicated to sober
drinking it's called heckit and they
even serve craft mocktails super cool we
have the owner on the line say hi to
Abby who watches on NBC New York
everybody what's up
Abby
hi hi so you say it's a great time to be
sober why it's actually the best time in
history to be sober because there are
hundreds of products now not just one
near beer but hundreds of alcohol-free
products designed just for people who've
given up alcohol you're totally I
remember when I was a waitress oh many
years ago they it was like Buckley or
buckler there was like this one beer
yeah yeah there was this one beer you
could get yeah I was like oh man you're
driving I was like anyway what's what's
on the menu we've got all kinds of
delicious things our best seller is the
Healer which see how purple it is people
love that that on Instagram yeah and uh
that doesn't try to be any alcoholic
beverage it's not um imitating an
alcohol-free beverage we do have uh
spicy margaritas and um virgin pin
coladas so there are drinks you'll
recognize from being in a regular bar
and then we have a lot of products that
are just stand on their own as something
that never had alcohol at all yeah fancy
fun drinks I like it that's fun it
looked like a fun drink looked like a
good time in a cup well thank you so
much Abby this is so cool and also it
makes it easier a lot of friends that
are sober and it makes it cool for them
to go and hang out and still have a good
time and still feel like they're like a
part of it in the same way that's very
cool that's why I opened the bar it was
I have a regular bar right across the
street and a couple of my real real
regular customers gave up alcohol for
assorted and sunry reasons and I thought
well I need to create a place where
there's a sense of community and a sense
of fun but where there isn't the
temptation of alcohol so that's what
this is for a that's super cool thank
you so much Abby I'm liking your post
right
now and that's not all ma'am our season
long partner pilot pin makers of precise
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor truly Unstoppable people
just like you ma'am just great ideas so
they're going to they're going to be
putting $1,000 in your tip jar how's
that
sound what hell of a
drink thank you Abby thank you to all
our guests this hour Jodie Foster Sher
Cola Derek and N you have a great day
and it it's not Chang
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home